sudán un estado frágil al borde de la
crisis y donde la gente sigue clamando
por justicia tres años después de una de
sus masacres más mortíferas 3 de junio
de 2019 centro de jartúm habían pasado
dos meses desde que el longevo dictador
omar al-bashir había sido derrocado como
presidente en un golpe de estado un
consejo militar de transición asumió el
poder pero los manifestantes de esta
sentada pedían un retorno incondicional
al gobierno civil
[Música]
una lluvia de balas mientras las fuerzas
de seguridad trataban de disipar las
manifestaciones más de 120 personas
fueron asesinadas algunos de sus cuerpos
arrojados al nilo mientras los médicos
informaron de decenas de violaciones
cometidas por el personal paramilitar
varios meses después un gobierno civil o
militar tomó el mundo dirigido por el
nuevo primer ministro de sudán abdalá
hand ok encargó un comité de
investigación que descubriera la verdad
sobre los asesinatos de junio con el
objetivo de llevar a los autores ante la
justicia posteriormente se escucharon
las declaraciones de 3.000 testigos
mientras que los miembros del ejército
fueron interrogados en persona pero la
pandemia retrasó los procedimientos y la
investigación quedó en pausa en octubre
de 2021
el breve atisbo de democracia de sudán
se detuvo cuando los militares tomaron
el poder del gobierno de transición
andoc fue arrestado junto con otros
funcionarios y el general de mayor rango
abdel fattah luján tomó el control del
país
para corregir el camino de la revolución
decidimos implementar el estado de
emergencia en todo el país el 9 de marzo
de este año las fuerzas de seguridad
allanaron las oficinas del comité de
investigación del 3 de junio sólo dos
días después de que suspendieran todas
sus actividades ahora que el país
conmemora el tercer aniversario de los
asesinatos los manifestantes han vuelto
a salir a la calle para exigir que los
responsables rindan cuentas nos para
continuaremos nuestra lucha y no nos
detendremos tenemos hermanos que
murieron tenemos mártires tenemos
víctimas y no cederemos nuestros
derechos albuja continuaremos nuestra
revolución y si dios quiere ganaremos
mientras tanto la búsqueda de justicia
continúa en sudán